[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to chess
openings explained i'm your instructor
tonight
nick risco one of the instructors here
at the st louis chess club
and we're gonna be going over the
sicilian defense the
pin variation tonight and i gotta be
honest i was a little in
uh over my head for this one i thought
it was gonna be super easy to prepare i
thought you know
this line isn't supposed to be great for
black but it's important for white to
know what to do
and when i went looking for resources to
study for this
one of our own videos popped up a long
time ago
before i started working here by grand
master yasser sarawan
and i watched that lecture and i was
like oh yeah he's just going to be beat
the pin variation
uh it turns out yasser loves the pin
variation he played it a lot in
scholastics and
i realized the real challenge for this
week was i have to refute a grand master
so let's get into it we're going to be
going over the
pin variation of the sicilian defense
starts off with pawn to e4 and pawn to
c5 this is the sicilian
uh and knight f3 so knight f3 by white
will
lead to the open variations
uh most commonly there are some
sometimes we play knight c3 and try and
go into like a uh
i guess like a king's indian attack with
g3 but more often than not it's going to
lead to an open sicilian
and here in the pin variation black is
going to play pawn to e6
normally you might see pawn to d6 or
knight to c6
but e6 is also playable
and here white normally goes d4
opening up the position black should
capture
the idea is you're giving up a flank
pawn for a center pawn
at the cost of development white will
have a very nice knight here on d4
but black has an extra center pawn
and here black goes knight to
f6 there are other variations where they
can go
a6 or queen c7 first this will lead to
the the khan or tymanov paulsen systems
but tonight we're going to look at
knight 2 f6
and knight 2 c3 here
black can still transpose into the other
systems by playing
a6 queen c7 or knight c6 but tonight's
main focus
is the pin variation and that is bishop
to b4 what is the point of this move
the point is that black is going to be
putting increased pressure on the pawn
on e4
if white is not careful and they play
something like bishop e2
trying to develop normally there's
bishop c3
pawn c3 and knight e4 and white is
already down upon
okay so back to this position
after knight to c3 i should mention some
of the other moves
that white can play or rather why
white shouldn't play these moves
probably the most common one you'll see
at a scholastic level
is pushing the pawn to e5 right away and
this one is a mistake
i'll give the chat 10 seconds try and
find the move
shouldn't be too difficult
see some compliments for yasser in the
chat yash is a great guy but
uh i can't think like that for this
lecture i have to think you know this
guy knows nothing about chess
i need to beat him in this line that he
did
that he covered so here we see uh in the
chat emblazoned was first
queen to a5 check hitting the king
hitting the pawn it's a fork after
knight to c3 to block
queen e5 and black is better they are
just
up upon very comfortably not much
counter play white can get from this you
have to like block with the bishop
and castle king's side and just hope
that you can get play with your pieces
later
uh it should be noted blocking with
queen may not be the best
because queen takes on d4
so e5 mistake by white so if you're
playing this with black there are some
tricks very early on
now what happens if white plays bishop
to d3 maybe they notice
hey the knight is attacking the pawn
there are some systems where going
bishop to d3
first may actually be useful where if
instead of going knight to f6
black may consider going to a6 first
bishop d3 can actually be fine here
same against queen 2 c7 going bishop to
d3 is not the worst move in the world
and can transpose to a moroxy bind
but here against knight f6 and bishop d3
the position is a little bit different
now after knight to c6 your knight on d4
is hit and it's hanging so you have to
do something about it
and probably the best way for white to
deal with this is just trade it off
once you trade it off black will capture
with the b-pawn
and after castles black hits you with d5
and should be fine here i don't think i
would go as far as to say black is
completely better
but they they survive the opening
so bishop d3 may not be the best move in
this line
okay so if bishop d3 doesn't work what
if you try another
kind of weird looking move knight to d2
uh you're blocking your queen and your
bishop so not very recommended but let's
see what exactly is wrong with this move
after
knight to d2 black has the flexible
pawn to d6 and you get black playing a
cheveningen sicilian where it's very
flexible and normally
white can follow up with g4 but here
you want to make sure you are developing
your pieces protecting your center
because after bishop to d3 black just
has some very comfortable development
here
knight b to d7 and once you castle black
has this
pretty cool move knight c5 and
it seems a little strange at first
you're moving the same piece more than
once in the opening and you're only on
move seven
but the idea is that now white almost
has to give up
this bishop for the knight and normally
that's going to be a good exchange for
black giving up a knight
for one of the bishops
so knight to c3 is the preferred move
there hasn't been any really weird weird
moves by black here that
will give us problems like the other
moves do and knight c3
invites the bishop to come to b4 and in
yasser's lecture he said knight c3 was
required for white to dream of having an
advantage
at least there i think we can agree
now here after bishop to b4 like i said
the issue is with our e-pawn so what
should we do
with this pawn how do we get rid of
this pressure how can we continue
without losing a pawn
some players might choose knight to b5
and here knight to b5 is okay
black can hit you with pawn to d5 and
break in the center right away
and then you play like e5 get the knight
to move to e4
and then the only move here that white
really has is queen to g4 i think this
is the only move where they can get a
solid advantage uh if you can even call
it that it's still pretty equal after g6
but this is a try for white i don't
think it's the best
try white has though let's see a
another move that they have here instead
of
knight to b5 is bishop to d3
again trying to protect the pawn
uh and here it also doesn't really seem
like white is going to
to have a great time here after knight
to c6 again the knight
is hanging so you have to do something
about it
you can take and black takes with the
pawn now you play pawn to e5
knight to d5 hitting the knight twice
it is pinned and
here bishop d2 is fine it will lead to
an equal game
there's only one move here where a
computer saying white will
will have an advantage and that's with
queen to
to g4 hitting the pawn on g7 putting
pressure on the bishop on b4
and here it's saying white is going to
be fine
again i don't think this is going to be
the best try for white i think white has
more
more that's possible for them to get out
of this position
after something like g6 castles
pawn to h5 attacking the queen already
uh while black's pieces aren't perfect
the pawns are really strange all on the
uh all on the white squares so this
light square bishop is going to probably
struggle in the future
black's at least getting some play
hitting the queen
a move like queen to c4 makes sense
now the bishop has to go back to e7
because of the threat of taking on d5
with the knight
and removing the defender of the bishop
so after bishop to e7
94 looking to go into f6 or d6
and pawn a5 this move or
i guess this position should be better
for white
but we're going to look at what's
probably a better continuation
i think the only other move here that's
worth looking at
is bishop to e2 and after bishop to e2
there is um bishop takes c3 bc3 and
knight e4
or even just knight e4 first and white
is going to be down
upon but up the development i wouldn't
recommend this
i don't like i don't like the idea of
white just giving up the pawn
so after looking at all those
alternatives all those other candidate
moves
i should go into what the actual move is
and that is pawn to e5 if you are
looking like you're going to lose a pawn
uh you know if there's no good way to
defend it always consider moving it
so pawn to e5 what exactly is happening
here
while you're hitting the knight and it's
inviting the knight to come to d5
or e4 and there is a third move that
we're going to cover tonight
just because it's an old line a little
tricky but
it's just completely losing for black
we'll cover that move first that move is
queen to a5
trying to put another attacker on c3
ignoring the threat on f6
maybe threatening to capture on e5 but
let's just see how
white gets out of this first
you take the knight this was the entire
point of playing e5
so ef6 bishop takes c3
pawn takes c3 and queen takes c3 and it
looks
like black is going to win a rook
and get their material back now here
there's two obvious candidate moves the
one that most people may fall for
is bishop to d2 they say my rook is
obviously more
more important than the knights the rook
is worth more than a knight i should
save the rook
but after bishop to d2 queen takes d4
if you take on g7 then queen takes g7
and this is a relatively equal position
white may have some trouble getting this
light square bishop out in the future
because g2 is being hit
so this one black should not be
struggling
too much for they can play pawn to d6
get their
light square bishop out on d7 and c
c6 so instead of playing
bishop to d2 here they should play queen
to d2
and here's the idea queen takes the rook
this was the threat
but now the pawn takes on g7 forcing
black to go
rook to g8 otherwise you're going to
either take the rook or just you know
push and make a queen
and the key move here is pawn to c3
and once we take a look at this position
we ask ourselves what is happening
with black's queen and you start
realizing well the queen
doesn't really have any squares to go to
it can't go to b2
can't go to c3 can't go to a2 those are
all protected by the queen
the only square it can go to is b1
so let's say we try and go queen b1
trying to get out maybe go
queen to b6 well
there is bishop to d3
and after queen to b6 this position
should just be winning for white because
of the development
of the pieces you're going to castle
next black has done
nothing to develop their queen side
and here it should just be should just
be winning there's no
great continuation for black after
bishop to a3
the bishop is probably looking to go to
f8
just protect the pawn and then the only
way to break it up is to sacrifice a
rook
for a bishop and a pawn if they try to
take on g7 right away there's always
queen h6
attacking the rook and once the rook
moves back you have queen
h7 hitting the rook again rook is
actually
trapped in this position
uh let's see i believe there was another
move played
instead of queen to b6 or sorry rather
instead of
instead of like bishop to a3 there are a
couple queen moves as well that have
been played in
actual games the move queen h6 right
away
was played in the game krivia sveely
versus pakssashvili
in desin in 1996 and the continuation
was queen to c5
castles queen to e5 again trying to to
get something happening with this queen
but knight b5 looking to go into c7 or
d6 if this queen moves
knight to a6 protecting against any
knight 2 c7 fork
bishop to g5 queen takes g7
knight d6 king f8 and now
queen h5 not looking to trade the queens
the idea is that bishop h6 is coming and
there's no way to
protect against bishop h6 while also
keeping your queen on f7 preventing mate
another move inside of queen h6 is queen
to g5
and this is more played than queen h6
but i think queen h6 is
probably more accurate now there's queen
d8 looking to trade off the queens and
here
is actually a good idea because bishop
g5 comes with check
and after the king moves bishop f6 will
hold on to this pawn forever
and it's just going to be hard for for
black to ever get rid of this past pawn
it's always going to be one move away
from promoting
so back to the main line i think queen
a5 is just losing
you just have to remember that after you
take the knight
when they take on c3 with the queen you
should play
queen to d2 and give up the rook and you
just have to remember to play pawn to c3
so queen a5 busted
okay the other move black can think of
i guess two moves is knight to d5 and
knight to e4 we will cover
knight to e4 first because i think this
is the worst option
due to queen to g4 and the queen is
hitting the knight and the pawn on g7
white should get a better position here
after queen g4
what are the follow-ups for black well
let's start with uh
queen to a5 some of the same ideas just
piling up on c3
but here there is queen takes g7
and you're threatening the rook the the
main move here
is excuse me rook to f8
after bishop h6 you have this threat to
take on
f8 if this bishop ever goes knight takes
on c3
is a move here and white has this little
move
pawn to a3 the idea is that once this
knight moves away
you capture on b4 it's the piece that's
checking you so uh knight to c6
developing another piece instead
makes a lot of sense knight to b3
hitting the queen
queen takes e5 it's forking the king and
queen so you have to take
the knight takes now after ab4
this knight moves back to safety
threatening the pawn
bishop takes f8 king takes f8 and
after all those moves white emerges up
an exchange
so rook f8 now what if
instead of rook f8 black tries to give
this
check first get rid of the bishop with
check well here you just take on b
or sorry you take with the b pawn on c3
and after the queen takes back
the very important move here king
to e2 king to e2 is winning for white
the other move king to d1 is actually
winning for black because you're just
giving up this knight with
check and then they're going to follow
up with knight f2
say bishop d3 knight of two you're
losing a rook
so you have to remember to go to e2 and
if the queen takes the knight then
your queen takes on h8 with check and
you're allowed to do this because they
didn't capture with check on d4 your
king was out of the way on e2
so here uh same idea if they take your
rook
they you just take their rook with check
with a winning position
so the move that black should elect to
play here
is rook to f8 and again we're going to
go bishop to h6
threatening to take and now queen c5 you
have to protect
this rook and white will play
knight to b3 hitting the queen the
knight was also attacked
so knight to b3 makes sense now this
does allow the scary looking
queen to f2 after queen to f2 you can
play king to d1
and your bishop and knight control the
mating square
this kind of idea was also seen in the
copycat variation
of the vienna game which we also did a
lecture on a few weeks ago
where black will get this you know queen
to f2 checking the king and it looks
very scary because it looks like you're
getting mated
but when you look at this position uh
you actually ask yourself what threats
does black have and black doesn't have
any threats
and even though black has delivered
these scary looking checks they don't
have a way to protect the rook on f8
and now it is black's turn to run the
king around the board
so you have to move the king to d8 so it
can go to c7
or you have to push the pawn uh to get
an escape square but either way the
queen is going to take on f8
with check and then the king is going to
run to his escape square
and then after something like bishop to
d3 hitting the knight
your rook is ready to come to f1 maybe
snap f7 off the board why is just
actually very safe here
so let's go back that is
with the um the knight to e4 line
like i said queen g4 should
be good for you and that was against the
queen a5
line here there's also uh if
black chooses to take on c3 with the
knight
and here you cannot take on c3 because
of bishop c3
and it is a fork with the king and rook
so here if you can't take on c3 what
should you do
you have to make a bigger threat you
have to go queen takes g7
attacking the rook and now if you know
the the knight moves anywhere if it goes
like back to d5 you have pawn to c3
blocking the check
and now the queen is also hitting h8 you
can't protect both white will emerge
fine there's just too much pressure here
on the rook again if they try and go
like rook to f8
there's always bishop to h6 to add this
pressure threatening to win the exchange
in this specific position though taking
the bishop
first is going to be better because
bishop h6 is always going to be a
resource
so this knight to e4 idea
i don't think is going to be working out
for
black if they play rook f8 first
this was seen in the game sabo versus
mecanus
in kamari 1939 uh
sabo is a very both of these players are
very strong gm's for their time
and sabo actually ended up playing in
the very strong
zurich 1953 candidates tournament
so mcanis plays rook to f8 and
zabo continues with pawn to a3
now when the knight moves you can just
take on b4
because just take the piece that's
checking you you give up the knight on
d4
and follow up with bishop to g5 hitting
the queen
queen has to move and now you get the
thematic bishop
h6 queen takes before check you block
with c3 which
is also a fork knight goes to f5 hitting
the queen
c takes b4 knight takes g7 bishop g7
rook g8 and now bishop f6
and white has a fantastic position here
the bishop is contr protected by the
pawn so this bishop is always going to
be
kind of paralyzing black's center here
it's going to be a little hard
for black to push this d pawn and black
still has not developed anything on the
queen side
so i i couldn't find any real move after
queen to g4 that would give
black a uh a real good shot at equality
which leaves us with the main line
knight to d5 knight to d5 is the best
move here
uh probably the only move where black
can hope to to have an advantage at any
point
and here there are quite a few moves
quite a few moves here for white
knight to b5 is obviously one that
deserves consideration
looking to go to d6 and this should be
fine but i think this is going to be
more equal give black more more hope
they have pawn to a6 hitting the knight
and after knight d6
there's take take and knight takes c3
and after
the b-pawn takes on c3 white has not
prevented black from doubling the pawns
so this can be a long-term weakness
black can end up actually
i think my analysis for this line ends
here sorry um
after b takes c3 just white hasn't
prevented the doubling of the pawns
which gives black some long-term targets
one of the benefits is that you do have
this pawn on d6 that kind of freezes
black's center so knight b5 does deserve
consideration
i think the other move i guess the other
serious contender and this is the move
that yasser recommended white
to play in his video was queen to g4
yasser also made the claim that this is
the only good move
i do agree this move is good for white
let's say black decides to play castle
to defend the pawn
there is bishop to h6 threatening mate
in one
the only way to defend this is pawn to
g6
and you can win an exchange on f8 so now
white is up material
uh the problem is this pin on c3 is
still really annoying
uh so you have to play queen to g3 in
this position
to help defend you can also try knight
to e2
it's another interesting idea you do
block your light square bishop
but after like knight to c6 you have
queen g3 and you're still doing all
right
but i would just recommend playing queen
g3 first
and now queen to c5 you always see black
trying to put more and more pressure
on c3 uh very thematic because this is
the entire idea of the variation it's
why it's called the pin variation you
pin the knight you try and win something
on c3
and now 92 is going to be your best move
because it does bring in another
defender
knight to c6 bringing this knight into
the game just castle queen side now this
can look
very scary not going to lie to you there
black
does have four pieces on the queen side
and
white only has you know a rook and two
knights and their king is over here but
there's
if you look at where black's pieces are
pointing all the threats are on
c3 it's not really going to be on the
king
on the back row knight 2 c3
knight 2 c3 queen e5
so this lets black win the e pawn
and in the mco 15 and if you look at the
database
but specifically mc015 nick defermion
says
you know uh once black wins the e pawn
gives black almost equal chances
uh d5 here and we enter this uh weird
position where white
does have the rook for the bishop but
black does have
this nice pawn center which does give
some compensation not to mention the
bishop pair
so this end game is probably going to be
one of the best positions black can hope
for at least from the analysis that i've
done
this is probably going to be black's
best hope
the other idea that black has after
queen g4
instead of castling is playing king to
f8
it looks weird because you're not
castling but the idea is that
you're not really going to be allowing
bishop to h6
threatening mate and 1 because you can
just take the bishop
so here white is just going to have to
play something like bishop to d2
break this pin and black can kind of
open up the position after pawn to d6
you'll see pawn takes on d6 and instead
of taking back right away
because black is always going to have
queen takes d6
you will see them take on c3 first
and white will capture with the pawn
black has
given white the opportunity to get the
bishop pair
it wouldn't make much sense for white to
capture with the bishop
just to get rid of that advantage and
with these doubled pawns on the board
it also makes sense for white to just
keep an extra set of pieces
on the board so that way white has more
to work with
so now queen takes d6 and then like
bishop d3 here and not many games go
down this
this line but black should be aware that
this is an idea
and white should also be aware that like
king f8 is a real move
so queen to g4 is uh
probably one of the the better moves for
whites probably the second
best so we looked at knight b5 in this
position
we ended up looking at queen to g4 but
now this is where i'm going to
to go away from what yasser mentioned in
his video
and i am going to recommend the move
bishop
to d2 and in yasser's video
he was saying you know after bishop to
d2
this shouldn't really be great for white
because there is still chances
for black to double white's pawns
however i don't think that
in this move order is going to be such a
big deal
there's quite a few moves here
so let's see after bishop to d2
what does black have i should mention uh
let's actually take a look first that uh
knight to c6
i actually gave this move a double
question mark and i want to see
if chat can figure out the idea of why
why knight to c6 a very natural looking
move
might be a problem here i'll give you
guys a
about a minute here see if you can find
why knight c6 may not be
the best move for black
looking in the chat here knight riders
asking if we can do a video on the grand
p
pre and the uh the petrov defense
uh yeah so those uh i think we actually
may have
a short video on the petrov if we
haven't i need to get in touch with
danny to make sure
we can get that happening but we do have
material for the petrov that is prepped
and i am experimenting with the grand
prix
i've never played it too seriously so i
want to make sure i can get familiar
with it before i give a lecture on it
musa tuwani is uh recommending queen to
h5 i don't know if queen to h5 is going
to be the move here
after queen to h5 you just hang your
knight on d4
so not really sure what you're getting
out of here
stefan is recommending knight takes d5
but stefan can you please
explain why knight takes d5 would be
good
anxiety squid is recommending bishop to
b5
pinning the knight on c6 but this is not
an actual pin
this pawn is still on d7 so this knight
is pinned to nothing it can still take
on d4
and you're going to be down a night
schuler is saying white gets access to
d6
and this is the idea so couple that idea
with uh stefan's knight takes d5
white should actually just get a
positionally winning position
after knight takes d5 bishop takes d2
queen d2 85
and now white gets either knight to b5
or knight to f5 but either way that
knight is going to get to d6 and this
square d6 is a permanent outpost
for the knight there are no pawns on the
c and e
files to kick the knight away so this
knight is going to go to d6 is
going to be a very strong piece be very
annoying for black to deal with
after a move like castles and knight d6
with this knight also blocking the
d-pawn it's going to be even more
difficult
for black to successfully develop this
bishop on c8
i should mention that putting the knight
on d6
is not to get the bishop on c8
this knight on d6 is way better than
this bishop that can't go anywhere and
has no influence on the position
so knight to d6 is the idea
now if you try something like you know
knight
takes c6 this is going to get rid of
your positional advantage black just
takes what they're deep on
and suddenly what looked pretty
difficult for black
space wise and development wise actually
looks great
they now have this fantastic pawn chain
into the center
their bishop is open to develop to a
square of its choosing
they're ready to castle queen is able to
get out
just this this position is so much
better for black than what was
a move ago so do not take on c6
if you don't want to go knight f5 right
away this idea still lingers
for a few moves you have an idea of
castling first this is doable
but black gets to castle and then now
um let's see i think the one problem
with uh
knight takes d4 to eliminate this idea
of the knight getting to d6
is after the queen takes there's no way
to protect d5 so you'll win a center
pawn
so you'll see a move like castles and
then white should continue
knight to b5 again going to
d6 and the reason why i would suggest b5
in this situation
is in case the queen moves anywhere it's
not going to go to g5
but if the queen moves anywhere you do
have knight c6 hitting the rook as well
but i think either square should be fine
even if the knight takes on e5 you can
still go knight d6
and then your queen is going to take on
d5 in the very near
future so uh
i see uh super pomax was just mentioning
why can't black
play knight takes e5 and they still can
it's just white will still get the
knight to d6 and then this pawn on d5 is
going to hang
so very good question
okay so knight to c6
looked like it would be a natural move
looked like it would be fine you're
hitting a hanging piece but this is just
positionally losing
so what other options does black have
black does have the option of taking
on c3 with the bishop and here
pawn takes on c3 and queen c7 and i
believe this is the line yesterday gave
as to why bishop d2
may be a poor choice because black is
threatening
both of these pawns there is a strong
move
pawn to f4 the idea with pawn to f4
is uh you're still keeping your lines
open for your pieces but then you're
going to use this pawn on f4
hopefully to break into black's position
there are a couple ideas here but let's
see if black goes for the most
direct knight take c3 well now there's
queen to f3
you're hitting the knight threatening to
win it and after
knight to d5 white is going to be fine
after knight to b5 and again the knight
is going to get to d6
and here white just has a crushing
position
if they don't take on c3 they can try
castling
castling is an option for black and here
white can get away with just natural
development bishop
to d3 and let's say the knight takes on
c3 again trying to punish white for not
protecting this pawn enough there is
queen to h5 now
threatening mate in one g6 is the only
move to defend
and queen to h6 maybe the idea is going
to be h4 h5
rip open the h file maybe you're gonna
hope for
pawn to f5 and get away with bishop g5
to f6 that's a bit of a long plan though
black does get some play with pawn to d6
but taking will hit the queen the queen
recaptures
um or just queen goes to c5 rather
you don't want to give up the knight so
recapturing is actually just a blunder
you hang a piece
so you'll see queen to c5 and now this
knight on f3 is going to reroute itself
uh sorry from d4 to f3 and it's going to
go to g5
where now white is going to be
threatening h7 and there's no good way
to defend
so castles is also going to lead to a
very strong attack
for white
okay so as if the bishop takes first now
the main line here
uh instead of giving up the bishop is to
take on c3 with the knight
and here is going to be black's best try
it is very important that white
remembers to take on c3 with
the pawn now this is the point that
black is trying to make is that white
has to double these pawns to get a very
good advantage
the problem with taking with the bishop
is that bishop takes c3
pawn takes c3 and you're met with queen
to c7 that is forking your pawns
and because you haven't developed your
queen yet there is no queen to g3 to
protect both
and this will lead to a better position
for black
so you need to remember take on c3 with
the pawn do not take with the bishop
and now here black is met with a choice
where do they put this dark square
bishop
it's being attacked so you can't just
leave it there
what are the options
here for black there's probably two good
options here
but there is one option bishop a5 which
i do want to cover
i do not think this is the best line
you're met with
queen to g4 hitting this weak g7 pawn a
theme that we've been seeing throughout
the night
you have to castle to protect it uh if
you try something like king to f8
uh it's still playable but white just
brings in the pawn to h4
going to just run this pawn up the board
try and break up the pawn structure uh
so
castle's the most played bishop to d3
hitting h7 so again just bringing more
pieces into the attack on the king side
you might see pawn to d6 we saw this in
one of the other lines where black is
trying to open up the position a little
bit
but here again we will see a knight
maneuver to bring the knight
into the attack knight f3 now if you
take it can be a bit dangerous there's
actually a greek gift here
where white can take on h7 and after
king takes
uh you have knight g5 or queen h5 but
i'm looking at knight g5
because that seems to be the most like
most common way people will recognize
the greek gift
and then wherever the king goes they're
going to either get mated or white is
going to win
a severe amount of material
so black needs to be careful after
knight to f3 because there are the
bishops on d2 and d3
a queen on g4 greek gifs do exist
so the best way to deal with this is
just play pawn to g6
and now we have this kind of fiend keto
pawn structure
and the best way to counter those is run
your h
pawn up the board d takes e5 here
and there is no greek gift because g6
was played
but now white has pawn to h5
now best move for black here
surprisingly is
pawn to f5 hitting the queen so you
don't get away with taking on g6
but you do get away with a bishop
sacrifice
bishop takes f5 and what is the point if
ef then you have queen c4
check the king if it moves
is going to run into a lot of trouble
after the h
pawn takes on g6 you can't really take
back because of
bishop h6 winning an exchange right off
the bat
and some mate threats if you just move
the king
move the king back that is to the h file
so this can lead to some problems if
black moves the king that's why you will
see
them block with the rook
and this is still going to lead to a
very crushing attack by white
after this h file opens the knight is
going to come to g5
it's protected by the bishop so no queen
takes
queen c7 looking to trade the queens and
now as long as white doesn't trade the
queens they will be fine
queen to h4 and this position
uh was reached in the game wagman bald
and bl 1981
stockfish gives it a an evaluation of
like plus
20. so bishop a5
a little inaccurate leaving the king
side
pretty weak so you will see other moves
here
bishop to f8 is one move
and here white plays bishop to d3 this
is going to be fine this may be the best
try for black is bishop to f8 though it
seems very impractical to do so
because when you look at black's pieces
it looks like black's setting up for the
next game
black is just going to be so far down in
development that is hard to imagine that
they're going to
to launch an attack to win
but this position does seem fairly
balanced so i do have to say bishop to
f8
does look pretty good for black however
the most played move is bishop e7 and
this is the main line
so this is what we're going to be
covering
for the rest of the lecture is bishop to
e7
and here white gets the move queen to g4
again just hitting this g7 pawn
hopefully it's sticking by now that uh
if black has not castled you do have
queen g4
as a strong threat now there are
three different moves here for black
i think we will start off with king 2f8
king to f8 is a move here bishop to d3
your standard development bringing in
the other piece
and now pawn to h5 trying to hit the
queen so i will say
you know black does have some tricks
they can go for hitting the queen with
h5
is one of them but after something like
queen to f4
keeping it lined up with the king may be
looking to play bishop
g6 soon you'll see black play pawn to d6
here bishop to g6 works now queen to e8
to defend
knight to f3 and the knight is going to
try and go to g5
or if allowed white is going to take on
d6 and then play knight
e5 so to stop this idea of taking a 95
black plays pawn to d5 and here i think
white just has a very comfortable
position you can play pawn to h4
to kind of freeze this h pawn
and also to get away with knight g5 you
can't play it right away
because bishop takes g5 and when you
take back the bishop on g6 hangs so i do
want to
mention this
so okay king f8 seems a little
a little slow it looks like they're just
trying to catch up to the defense
the other move we should look at here is
to do
pawn to g6 uh i thought this was
i thought this was going to be black's
best try if it's not going to be bishop
to f8 on the previous move
pawn to g6 does give some
some work for white to do to get an
advantage
but we're going to go knight to b5
looking to go to d6 you'll see this pawn
on e5
all the way from the very beginning
makes it very hard for black just to
push this d-pawn
and if this d-pawn is still on d7 knight
to d6 is always going to be
some idea
uh black does castle here and
pawn to h4 you can try going bishop to
h6 but this is going to lead
to more of an equal position uh if
black is willing to give up the exchange
knight to c6
and now black is going to start catching
up in some of the development that
they've been lacking this entire time
if they do go rook to e8 this is still
going to be better for white
after pawn to h4 and this attack is
going to be very strong
so you just have to be willing to give
up this exchange because after bishop
takes f8
you have bishop takes f8 and now if h4
you have like knight takes e5 and you're
hitting the queen and it's really hard
for the queen just to
to find a way in without the support of
the bishop on the dark squares
okay so uh pawn to g6
and then bishop h6 is an idea but the
best idea
for white here is just h4 right away
now knight two c6 hitting the e5 pawn
you should probably protect this pawn
pretty important center pawn it's what's
preventing black from breaking open in
the center
so after queen g3 there are two ideas
for black
we'll start with one that i think is
sub-optimal is pawn to a6
and now we see knight to d6 which was
the idea of knight to b5 in the first
place
bishop takes pawn takes and queen a5
getting the queen out looking for some
activity
is met with pawn to h5 the queen cannot
take because of the rook
the pawn cannot take because of the pin
we will see queen e5 check queen takes
e5
knight takes e5 captures on g6
f captures on g6 and a4
uh now while white's pawns are not
fantastic i have to be honest there the
pawns
are looking worse than blacks
white does have the bishop pair and for
now has stopped
any potential pawn play black may have
here
this bishop on c8 is still going to be
very difficult to develop you're gonna
have to play like b6
and then bishop to b7 but this is pretty
passive it can be met with rook to b1
and b6 is already being hit so after
bishop to b7
rook takes b6 you're losing a pawn here
for the bishop and i don't like to be
the guy that has to give up my material
just so i can get my pieces to work
properly so i
i don't really recommend the a6 move as
it just lets white
go through with their plan i think if
black has
any chance at surviving this position
it should be with the move f6 and
now i'm defying another grand master for
those who know
ben feingold never play f6
i think black has to play f6 here in
order to survive
uh so ef bishop takes f6
bishop h6 hitting the rook and here
uh black again has to be comfortable
giving away the exchange
if they try something like rook f7
they're just going to be met with pawn
to h5
and this g6 pawn is going to be captured
you can try playing g5 this is one of
the ideas
of giving up the f pawn is um that way
once sorry once white clears this out
there is a
after h5 pawn to g5
where did i just go in my notes h5 g5
okay knight d6
hitting bishop hitting rick if you go
rook to e7 here white can develop their
final piece
with the bishop to b5 move pawn to a6
hitting the bishop you just trade on c6
and castles
and here we see a very interesting case
of what looks to be zugswong
what move does black uh what move does
black
play here there's there's no great move
white is
a plus seven according to stockfish 13.
um i hate giving the engine eval like
that because it seems like i'm just
spitting off engine
lines but it's just there for a
reference so you guys can understand
how serious this position is
so rook to f7 trying to save the rook
is just going to jumble up black's piece
is no good defense
they do have to be okay giving up the
exchange
and should play something like pawn to
a6
and here the only move where white gets
a serious advantage as bishop takes f8
queen takes f8 or ab5
queen takes f8 um the knight can just go
to d4
and you save your knight if they take on
b5
then your bishop is safe it can go to h6
it's really up to black which piece gets
to come off of the board
they can try queen to a5 hitting the
pawn
and this can be a little dangerous
because they they do have the bishop
here don't forget
so you bring your bishop back to d2 you
defend the pawn in time and after pawn
to b4 trying to add a third attacker
you actually have this cute little move
rook to h3
bringing in another defender and after
pawn to d5
trying to give some squares for the
bishop white does have
a nice healthy advantage here as well
after pawn to h5
just keeping up with these general
attacking ideas
so i think this is um another
another position where black can can
survive
uh it's not like white has this huge
crushing advantage black
should go e5 here and the position is
like plus one and a half so
it's manageable but black does have some
some threats to deal with
so let's go back
go back that was the g6 line
if you're not going to play king f8 if
you're not going to play g6
you better play the main line with
castles
and here i'm sure everyone's starting to
get the idea now
the main move here is bishop to h6
threatening mate in one
only one response is g6 and here
white can take the rook right away uh
then bishop
captures you can just win the exchange
like this and then just be happy you're
up material and play from there
that's fine but white has better
white has better targets or bigger
targets
than the rook they want to go for an
onslaught against the king
so back to the rest of our attacking
ideas we see panda h4 again
again trying to go to h5 capture on g6
really rip open the king side and make
black kind of regret that the bishop's
on e7
and they didn't play some other you know
move order to get something like a
dragon with the bishop on g7
pawn to h4 going for this attack and
black will normally try queen to a5
forking the pawns but here like like i
mentioned earlier once this queen is
developed you have queen to g3
protecting both of the pawns
and black will normally try pawn to d6
the idea behind pawn to d6
here is you really just need squares to
develop your pieces
either your knight or your bishop can go
to d7 your knight also has the option of
going to c6
but you really really need to develop
the queen side as fast as you can this
is going to be
the main problem black faces it's just a
lack of development on the queen side
because they need to respond to all the
threats on the king side
and here a move that may not look so
natural
but we we've seen the idea before is
knight to b5
this will kind of over protect the pawn
on c3
it's also looking to just capture on d6
and maybe go to c7 trapping the rook if
black's not careful and moves their
queen
we will see a knight develop to d7
finally getting those pieces moving but
white
is just so quick on the attack they have
pawn to h5
black's best move is probably going to
be captures on e5
here and now white should just go ahead
with the attack
um the the game where this line
looks like it originated from was
zarnota
versus sulkis and warsaw 2005
and white elected to play pawn to f4
which is still fine but it gives black a
little hope
if they see a six um
after pawn to a6 both knights are being
threatened
so fe5 ab5 and this position
white is just a little bit better after
takes on g6
but after fg6 this rook does have an
open file now
and black starts to get play with his
pieces
uh you have to take on f8 after bishop
f8
the only move here for white is uh like
queen to h3 or rook to h3
and either of those may be a little
difficult to find over the board
queen h3 is a little more realistic but
h6
will hold the position and while white
is a little bit better here
this is not as clean as it could be
the move that was played in that game
after f4
was bishop to d7 trying to hit the
knight
and after fe 5 bishop b5 white was able
to trade off another set of pieces which
probably doesn't help black black needs
the pieces to generate counter play
and now after bishop to f8
white ended up winning this game after
uh material was traded off ended up
winning some end game
but like i said i don't think f4 is
going to be the best way
to to play against this knight takes e5
move i believe the best way is going to
be taking on g6 and just continuing this
brute force attack
so h takes g6 f takes g6 makes a lot of
sense
the rook is open and now only now
should white take the rook now that this
file is open the rook is actually doing
something it looks good on f8
now makes sense to snap it up off the
board you're able to leave it sitting
there for quite a while
because of the mate threats but now once
this rook is actually doing something
that makes sense to capture
because your opponent's rook is behaving
like a rook
so now bishop takes f8 and the move i
decided to choose
here for white was rook to d1 just
adding pressure onto the center
the queen would go to b6
the idea just going to b6 and then
defending d6
queen to h3 hitting h7 like before
and now h6 doesn't really do the job
after knight takes d6 this bishop is
overloaded
so after bishop d6 there's queen to
h6 and black is going to have some very
big problems here there's nothing
defending the king
so h6 does not do the job where it did
in the other line they have to play h5
where now this backwards pawn is the
only defender of the h pawn
and here white has bishop to e2
completing the development this knight
is adding pressure on d6 the rook's
adding pressure
the queen and rook are doubled on the h
file but this bishop wasn't really doing
anything
so bishop to e2 and now you're actually
looking
on your next move to play a very fun
sacrifice
bishop to d7 attacking the knight if you
don't do anything
too great you're just going to lose a
piece on b5
so here you have a couple moves knight
to d4
looks to be one of the better ones but
the move that is my favorite in this
position
is bishop takes h5 the idea is that
after they take on h5
you play queen takes h5 you're already
threatening matan 1 with queen to h7
bishop g7 is the only move to stop
this um this huge queen h7 check
and now after bishop to g7 black has
removed a defender of d6
and you can snap it with the knight and
stockfish 13 at depth 30 gives this
position
an evaluation of plus four uh even
though like throughout the position it's
saying it's only plus two you let it
think for a little while
white's just crushing here and it's very
hard to see
what black could have done better other
than playing some weird moves
so i think this line is probably going
to be the most instructive
for white in how to handle this position
but i do want to clarify
that there is the move bishop to f8 very
early on
after b captures bishop to f8 does look
like it gives black chances
but uh because there's so many ways
black can try and develop here
i believe it's just very hard to cover
them all
because it's like black is just starting
a new game they've reset their pieces
but white should still have a very
healthy advantage after bishop d3 just
up in development and black's targets
will appear naturally later on
but those are the lines that i prepared
for you guys tonight
this was the sicilian pin variation i'm
going to open up
just our last couple minutes here we
don't have as many minutes
as usual but i do want to open it up to
the chat if you guys have any questions
on any line you saw here
drop it in the chat please add a move
number and a variation
that way i can be more helpful
in knowing what line you're talking
about but if there are any questions
um now's the time get them in
i'm gonna scroll through the chat see
make sure i didn't miss anything
okay um
let's see pin the knight with b5 we
covered that
wasn't a real pin
let's see d6 is an outpost
hey buddy hi nick hi buddy i don't know
who you are
but hi um
a little off topic but some traps to
learn
uh i believe there's a book um it's like
what 700 opening traps uh
or something like that it goes over all
these really quick miniatures
i believe the author's bill wall i could
be very wrong on that
but if you're interested in traps that
book is a very good one
thanks for the compliments guys thanks
it's always a pleasure to do these
lectures
let's see what else anything on the
sicilian pin variation
i don't see any questions so it looks
like i did my job looks like i covered
this lecture
i covered the lines all for you guys if
you do have any questions in the future
drop them in the comments section below
we're also always looking
for suggestions on what openings to
cover if there's any opening that you
want to see done in the future
again once this video gets published on
youtube make sure you drop them in the
comments section below
i'm always checking them out for ideas
we're going to hop over to twitch where
we're going to do some tactics i'll see
you over there
and if i don't see you on twitch i will
see you here next week for openings
explained have a good night
[Music]
you